when it comes to the figure figure
out Jesus [ __ ] Christ figure it out
huh guys
every episode
the guy is cheating and then letters man
um
but do you guys think you can do is it
possible for one of you to knock the
other one out or it's not possible you
think honestly after this after this
much experience
man I don't know because I mean before
or rebality I mean fatal was like
like you know oh thank you man uh so
before already revaluate he was like
knocking out every single fighter
in the roster and he was doing a very
great job with that
yeah but with me I mean he he he hit me
with
his best punches and
do you think either one of you can knock
the other do you think you can knock him
out like act because you guys can
obviously you you can both find a way to
win
but is it possible I wonder because you
guys do I mean I mean the possibility is
always there man you know talking about
myself
I know
I don't have that kind of power to knock
one people out with like calls right I
know that you can work in the gym you
know you can work in your extension
conditioning you can work with your
exclusivity and you can work with your
Technique and your Precision oh yeah and
I try to to work within that like every
single time in the gym right but I know
I I don't bore with that [ __ ]
superpower
that is amazing
um
with that power but I mean I don't have
that that superpower but I have another
one yeah having a nice chin man yeah
what aspirations do you have right now
do you feel like is there a way where
you feel like you obviously get back to
the belt is that a goal right now up to
100 maybe I mean I was I'm pushing so
hard with my manager like man I don't
want another five minutes I want that
fight because I know
does I mean first of all I still
thinking I won the fight yeah
yeah look man I don't know I would agree
I I would agree that I don't know if he
won okay
you know uh I don't think that he I
don't believe that he did enough to win
that's where I stand with it
man so
I'm just trying to keep a balance
between
I certified
I feel like I won the fight
um and I want to be very positive about
it and at the same time I don't want to
be cocky but I say like oh I won the
fight I don't need to learn nothing
about it because I won and I don't want
to be that the stupid guy yeah okay
because that guy's not learning anything
exactly
so man I'm trying to watch the
perspective of the churches to see what
what they can maybe is watching that
fight and you know fix my mistakes and
that's it I mean I I know for sure I
just need to fix a little things
well it's almost interesting and I heard
you say this on another podcast talking
about the perspective of the judges
because some of them don't know that
much about wrestling about doing uh MMA
and they don't [ __ ] I don't even know
some of them I don't even know what
business they're in you know that's
important man I mean a lot of guys from
boxing yeah
because they are very a little bit old
like judging uh and a whole different
sport right oh yeah well you don't
notice sometimes I get position is so
important one certain like hook of the
foot or or keeping an arm out of the way
like things like that are so strategic
in that shape around it seems like my
point was
I mean ease
the guy throw three good punches in all
the in all the fight
he he got three knockdowns against me
and he was throwing a good kicks kid
tried a few takedowns in the fight he
never take me down really he gave me
yeah one time but was my fault because I
closed too much distance and just he
just told the dentist and he did it okay
that's my point but my point is man I
was touching his face every single day
you know like a musician huh like Tommy
Lee man I know I I I don't have the
enough power to knock a guy like cold
but I mean I'm doing my job oh you like
without the refrigerator effective
punches straight to his to his face
everything
yeah what else could you look I I don't
think that the title should have changed
hands man I really don't think that it
should have I wonder sometimes you
wonder if it's there doing something
because of the story they want this
bigger picture story but you know what
actually
right now I'm very excited then yeah
because I feel like I put a little bit
more drama now of this
um and at the same time I'm a little bit
mad with me like man that belt is yours
man and now
you wake up some monster inside of me
man yeah I like that huh some chupacabra
oh yeah
so man I don't know man it is
interesting at least your story now has
enough because that's your story your
story is this yes that's your story it
is so it's almost like
we can't be shocked when we get our
story you know we can't be surprised
it's like that's what God has for us he
has that story it's like your story is
that you are a guy who has to face
certain adversities everybody is and
that's the way that yours goes that's
interesting man but yeah I'm sure you
have more you certainly have more
purpose the guy the guy coming wanting
something always has more purpose
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one